un pronunciamiento que llega desde el
kremlin amenaza con recrudecer la guerra
en Ucrania el presidente de Rusia
Vladimir Putin anunció la movilización
parcial de reservistas y advirtió que
utilizará todos los medios posibles en
su ofensiva militar yo te llamo
creo que es necesario apoyar la
propuesta del Ministerio de defensa y el
Estado Mayor de realizar una
movilización militar parcial en Rusia
repito solo estamos hablando de una
movilización parcial solo a las personas
que están actualmente en la reserva
militar según
ministro de defensa de Rusia serán
convocados 300.000 reservistas y por
primera vez habló del deceso de casi
6.000 de sus militares
debo hablar de nuestras pérdidas hoy
nuestras pérdidas son de
5.937 personas
en medio de la contraofensiva ucraniana
y las derrotas militares rusas en
territorios clave del este de Ucrania en
el don Bass las autoproclamadas públicas
populares de donías y lugansk así como
las regiones de saborilla y jerson
ocupadas por el kremlin anunciaron la
celebración de referéndums de anexión a
Ucrania Putin respaldo la iniciativa
[Música]
haremos todo lo posible para garantizar
condiciones seguras para celebrar los
referendos para que la gente pueda
expresar su voluntad apoyaremos la
decisión sobre Su futuro tomada por los
residentes de la República populares de
doñex y Luján las regiones de saborilla
y gerson
Putin señaló occidente de un chantaje
nuclear hacia Rusia y recordó que su
país también cuenta con poder nuclear